[Music]
[Applause]
hey welcome back to the break room
everybody it's our daily show that keeps
you updated on the nerdy news you need
to know uh coming up on today's show
live from New Rockstar's headquarters
here we're gonna get some details on a
few interesting shows coming up uh
Daredevil Born Again heard of it
no Zach none of us
penguin the penguin penguin series heard
of it uh oh and we're gonna um have some
fun with these new AMC theater ticket
prices as a concept as a practice might
have some AMC what's it is it the pass
what's the average list the got a couple
of a list ticket holders here they might
have some strong thoughts on it uh uh
and then um of course we're going to
dive into some kind of it's a tiny thing
but it's a big Revelation some Guardians
the Galaxy vol 3 plot detail kind of
things that came out that lead to maybe
some big things for our friend Rocket
Raccoon so we're going to dive into that
head first our good buddy our good
little furry certainly part of them
heard of him Rocket Raccoon uh with me
to do all of that and more uh John Costa
here who's currently fiddling with his
microphone hey now you can hear him and
of course Jessica Clemens is here hi
Mike's always been on yes
uh and I'm Zach Huddleston and we're all
thrilled to be here on a Monday wait no
it's Tuesday sorry it does realize that
since we don't have episodes online yes
speaking of which this is a headline
later but uh let's just do it now this
week's episode of The Last of Us not
going to compete with the Super Bowl
right it's going to compete with nothing
it's coming up Friday people having a
fun Friday night with the Puppy Bowl
it's competing with the Puppy Bowl sorry
I think that those two things are far
enough apart in demographics
where you know I watch
um so if you're a fan of Our Last of Us
coverage on this channel we're going to
be putting out the after show for that
on Friday no normal break room episode
that day yes um I believe we're gonna
try to get a breakdown out on Friday too
TBD TBD Last of Us yeah yeah so tune in
6 p.m Pacific the normal time on Sunday
nights
oh yeah the show the show will Air at 6
p.m yeah sorry the yeah the last of us
will be airing at 6 p.m Eastern uh on uh
um HBO and then our show will be coming
out immediately after as close as we can
get it there uh with Jessica and Brandon
and Anna doing their best to analyze all
the fun revelations in episode five
implications is it five if you're a fan
of games uh or if you're not a fan of
the games it's gonna be a big one
I haven't seen it but I've played the
game yeah we know and and the trailer
the trailer at the end of episode four
looked pretty sick there's gonna be a
lot of action uh some new kinds of uh a
bloater might up here but who dies oh
we'll find out uh people been calling me
a blowter
and those people are not your friends
uh here let's uh we've already stepped
on one but let's get into officially the
headlines
there it is John's getting some uh some
help from Dash 11 on his microphone okay
so of course this is the week leading up
to the release of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania somebody on this panel saw
it last night and it was not me who
could it be is that me it's a it's a
Jessica Jessica and Eric Voss got to go
see uh quantumania at a very early
screening she's not gonna spoil anything
here John and I still don't know what
happens and we haven't anything spoiled
uh but we're continuing to get a little
trickle of news interviews those kinds
of things it feels like every day they
release three new clips it also said the
um the um what is it called when you can
release it finally information the
Embargo was the same day at 9 00 PM it
was is it normally the same day as the
person yeah yeah you could talk about it
on Twitter
it felt like when I saw Thor 11 Thunder
they were like give it a day wait a
couple days no it was the wakanda
forever pressed junk it because it was
way before the uh other things yes they
said if things have spoilers in them
please hold them for a couple weeks okay
and Jessica and all of us here at new
rockstars would not be spoiling anything
for you even if we were allowed to
because that's how much we value it Tang
dies no it looks like a hundred dollars
I I will 110 though she might uh but uh
in an interview with marvel.com the
writer of the film Jeff leviness uh said
that the quantum realm is like the
basement of the Multiverse so nice which
I I like that as a metaphor he said it's
this connected limbo outside of space
and time now that's not normally how I
Define basements but
made me so happy for so long everyone
was sort of like are there multiple
Quantum Realms in different universes is
it all the same thing what does the TVA
have to do with all this him saying like
it's the basement of the Multiverse
super helpful it seems like there's one
Quantum realm
um I haven't seen a movie yet
um and it kind of seems like that might
be where the TVA is situated have we
already talked about the featurette have
you guys already talked about the
featurette are we allowed to talk about
the future yet talk about the future the
future at the very beginning in the
future in the first eight seconds gen
Torah says uh you came from the same
place as him above and it's interesting
with that because it's like the what the
kitchen
like when you're in the Multiverse like
I guess maybe this is explained in the
movies but like do the people or do the
people that live in the quantum realm
understand the they're tiny yeah yeah I
don't know that's what we talk about in
inside Marvel this one okay we actually
get into it like what is the people in
the Multiverse 2 everything else or in
the quantum realm to everything else yes
tune in on Thursday for inside Marvel
this week uh Eric uh Jessica and Mt are
gonna be diving into that
um in other Marvel news Vincent
D'Onofrio once and forever our Kingpin
uh has shared some thoughts on the
upcoming Daredevil born again uh he's
doing this on Twitter Vincent D'Onofrio
again with Giancarlo Esposito and a
couple other people is just like always
good for some quotes yeah loves to talk
about his projects gives good quotes
always enthusiastic he's only two people
on Twitter it's Vincent donofrio and
James Gunn that's pretty much one of
those places
that timeline's going baby oh yeah
that's true they fill it up don't they
uh but he had this to say about the
series it's going to be very very cool
well thank you I'm glad that we got two
berries in there uh very different than
the Netflix show which as we know was
amazing yeah this is brand new and
really smart we are going to surprise
everyone one with it and yes it's going
to be really cool he's reaffirming the
really cool part he is everyone's
stepdad
use everyone step down
it's going to be lit is that what people
say oh my God we've been getting so I I
can't wait maybe maybe the Super Bowl I
don't know if we know but we've been
getting so many like quotes from even
Charlie Cox and Vincent D'Onofrio about
cast that are also coming and I'm like I
need something I need a little teaser I
need like a photo a photo concept or
anything anything because I keep getting
these little messages and I'm like I
know it's cool I know it's gonna be cool
I love Daredevil but please just give me
a little bit more I don't think they've
started shooting yet so I wouldn't
expect and this is uh 2024 I believe so
release probably yeah it's gonna be 2024
when they haven't started they have like
20 episodes oh yeah that's right it's
gonna be a long one and we might break
that up it might be like Andor where
they do like 10 and then wait eight
months and do another 10 or something
like that but
um yeah we're excited again it has been
a dry spell for Disney plus trailers
we're waiting on some uh not to step on
we're about to talk a little bit more
about Super Bowl chef but like we're
waiting on more secret Invasion news
we're waiting on Loki season two trailer
I mean word on the street we're not
getting a secret Invasion trailer at the
Super Bowl Eric and I were just talking
earlier today like they usually do some
kind of like here are six shows on
Disney Plus in one thing maybe we'll get
something like that but man we did get
some new Loki images which we'll talk
about in a second but I was like what's
expect do we know what's expected yeah
and we have a quick rundown or go ahead
uh for Marvel quantumania okay obviously
uh Guardians of the Galaxy sounds like
that's coming okay and then maybe the
Marvels oh I wish I would be very
excited apparently the footage that they
showed at Comic-Con was like some of
people's favorite footage also that is
that's pretty unprecedented in recent
history for Marvel to not only release
because like quantumanius doesn't come
out right so not even talking about the
next movie Guardians they're talking
about two movies from now right oh my
God they never do that that's the
Marvels it is they've been doing this
Cadence of like a six month thing so
we're right in that period of time six
months out from from the Marvels but
you're right they did kind of put this
Ant-Man movie in a weird spot where the
Super Bowl is a week before this movie
comes out they've already done so much
marketing for it so maybe they're ready
to move on again with no sign of any
Disney plus Marvel shows coming we still
have a release date for secret Invasion
so it's probably it's almost certainly
not February like we're fingers crossed
maybe we start getting it in March April
I've heard May
Feed Us fetus is considering Loki is
supposed to come out this summer too
does that mean that's not coming out
until August isn't there what Marvel
ones coming out May 5th okay well we can
keep going oh that's Guardians is the
big Guardians yeah yeah so we get two
okay yeah okay but um okay so speaking
of which though we did get some new
shots from Loki in a new ad uh from
Disney plus and Hulu actually Eric Voss
is breaking down those shots uh this
there's one this image that was in the
that was in the d23 trailer that they
showed
um I love that my head Cannon for this
is that like Loki shows up at the TVA
everything's been reset and he has to
like now run around and explain to
people that the time Keepers aren't real
and all this is the first episode he's
just kind of like running around the TVA
being like look it's fake do you think
do you think to do that he just pulls
out his phone and shows them all the
episodes of season hey you're right he
sits him down in front of a couch it's
like there's a guy eating an apple okay
but that guy is not the same
um yeah and and uh there were some other
images shared as well again Eric Voss
will be doing a breakdown oh this that's
a blurry images he's like swinging like
a dog or some kind of Staff or something
like that uh yeah again Eric will find
a thousand details on that enough to
fill nine minutes of a video I'm excited
to watch that should be out on the
channel shortly if it's not already
um and then in other news in the
director's commentary for wakanda
forever which again the digital release
of that it's out on Disney plus as of
the first episode you can buy it on like
Amazon or apple or whatever it is okay
and all that kind of stuff and the
Blu-rays nothing comes out next Tuesday
next Tuesday
um so there's a lot of kind of content
around those releases coming out
including director Ryan coogler revealed
that a shot of Chadwick Boseman at the
end of the movie was cut from uh
the first Black Panther movie yeah you
know there's that Montage at the end of
the movie
um this this one in particular I guess
uh coogler said it was like one of his
favorite shots from that first Black
Panther movie and they couldn't find a
place for it in the movie and the first
one is just him walking in you never see
the front of him he just walks in and he
cuts to the goats in the field
um so I don't know why they didn't put
that because it's like you show his back
you can just show his phone there was
there's focus on the goats and also let
you be fair it's like right after
killmonger dies yeah you don't want to
like a smiley King yeah
Yeah my cousin's dead I mean my friend
always had a joke about like uh deleted
scenes on DVDs or whatever that like
it's kind of like the chef coming out of
the kitchen at a restaurant being like
spaghetti spaghetti with meatballs and
here's all the ingredients that didn't
make sense in it like yeah you don't
want those like you gotta go with with
whatever you have but it is hey we'll
take any extra footage we can get
speaking of things that are coming out
of the channel soon yes Jessica's
breakdown re-break down we found a bunch
of new Easter eggs she found a bunch of
new Easter eggs I think it's this week
do we know when that's coming up this
week sometimes I thought it was today
but I think today my menu breakdown came
out it's so all-encompassing and
all-inclusive we're giving it to the
editors for a little extra time it is
it's a lot of stuff that I feel so bad
that they had to put your guesstimate on
how long that video is going to be it
shouldn't be too long I did this thing
where I say 250 words per minute
allegedly from what Riley said so I
divided it and it's around like 18 20
minutes
250 words a minute I wish I could take
seven five speed and uh it'll feel like
a regular video that's right that's
right oh very excited for that uh video
um speaking of future Marvel properties
director Matt shackman who held a lot of
Juan division
um shared that uh and he's going to be
directing the Fantastic Four film he
shared that it's going to start filming
in early 2024. I better hurry up they
better hurry well I mean if it's gonna
shoot in you know roughly a year from
now they better announce some cast
we did this show what a week ago two
weeks ago that was sort of like what
were the biggest mysteries yeah we're
excited for announcements coming up
that was our number one the cast for uh
Fantastic Four and it does seem like
it's gonna happen this year which is
great and there's rumors flying all over
the internet I don't believe any of them
and and maybe even if they even if it is
cast already and again it's such a big
intense thing to shoot one of these
Marvel movies these people got to clear
their calendar out right like they gotta
do six months of you got a certain
change broccoli getting ripped or
whatever or if you're playing bad Grim
you got a game like 400 pounds
the rumor is to play Ben grimmon that's
how I know it's not real is David dicks
no way that would be fun no that'd be
fun
[Music]
that hair on a brick yeah it's also a
good thing famously bald
um so hey maybe it's already been cast
and maybe they're just waiting to get
some of these other Marvel projects out
of the way because they don't want to
overshadow quantumania so you don't have
a movie coming out in the second half of
the year you know so they've got to kind
of stay in the well but maybe that'll be
their big news right pops later right
yeah
um and then on to DC news Colin Farrell
has done some interviews of course he's
uh Oscar nominated Colin Farrell
advantages of insurance uh a fun a fun
laugh a minute Riot fast on you can
watch on HBO Max now I I don't like
Martin McDonough but this is that's a
separate conversation for another
episode later yeah I don't enjoy any of
his work but um I I love Colin Farrell
though very talented actor and loved his
portrayal of penguin in the Batman but
he was talking about that series and
he's uh he said that um the show will be
eight episodes it's the first time we
heard of an episode length for that and
it will take place one week after the
events of the Batman and kind of be
about the penguin kind of rising up to
take Carmine falcones right this is a
power vacuum
we talked about this before and how it
would be like the water the flood would
still all be there right he's just like
in the middle
yeah okay let's go to the next headline
all right
um uh The Hollywood Reporter is gonna
play The Penguin sun or something stop
uh
uh Hollywood Reporter is saying James
Gunn will likely direct Superman Legacy
now that as part of his announcement he
mentioned he had been writing yeah right
he's been writing there were some
directors that were talked about uh last
week during the announcements that were
not attached to projects I think like
um I can't remember who they are now
obviously James mangled is doing Swamp
Thing but there are a couple other
people and so people were saying like oh
maybe you won't do Superman maybe he's
going to focus on you know seeing this
slate through and then once it's in
motion he'll he'll pick up a movie but
it sounds like he's gonna write it uh he
is writing it sounds like he's going to
direct it to yeah which is interesting
right I think like I've I've been
seeing a lot of people online saying
I don't want to see a James Gunn
Superman movie and I think like
directors especially as talented as
James Gunn are good enough to be
doing things that are not necessarily I
don't it's not going to be another
Guardians of the Galaxy movie I think
that's what they're nervous about is the
Guardians The Peacemaker and I was like
I think he's also really good at writing
uh in comedy words the voice of reason
for a crazier World outside so I think
Superman will be the straight man while
everyone else is like crazy around him
and I think I would love I think James
Gunn is really good at doing grounded
characters and I think this is the most
grounded character you need to do I mean
honestly he he gives I I personally feel
the most empathy I felt toward any
character in the previous you know 10
years of DC were some of those
characters in The Suicide Squad and I
feel similarly about we're doing this
we're having a discussion about rocket
in a minute he's a [__] raccoon you
know and like we care really deeply
about this character who's just right
here
technically not a raccoon you're right
well we'll find out
um you know and I I do think like he
doesn't get enough credit for the
moments where we cry in those movies
absolutely and and just because those
are often attached to a little furry
creature or a sentient tree doesn't mean
that he couldn't get that same kind of
pathway
which has been missing honestly for me
in this caval version of Superman it's
been missing a little bit of ironically
Humanity
um well and it's always a challenge with
Superman he's a literal Superman he's
greater than us so how to make that
character sympathetic I think is a
really fun challenge for James Gunn
right
um if he makes me cry over Superman then
I'd be like wow he's gonna oh he's gotta
beasts and tears while we're talking DC
I just want to draw attention to
Jessica's mug here uh this is a brand
new product available at nerd Riot uh
Dodge shop our merch store uh based on
one of our all-time great thumbnails
that became a meme does he know with
kind of a Paul Dano I love it I love the
what is this kind of art it's
impressionistic I don't know I don't
know John how would we Define that
copyright uh uh that's right yeah and
then I'm gonna the other great
um meme uh from our thumbnails what was
he cooking with kind of an
impressionistic uh Thanos there over his
pot uh one of the other great uh meme
thumbnails from new rockstars in the
last uh couple years crazy that a
thumbnail that I made in Photoshop three
years ago is now on a mug
these two memes especially the does he
know kind of grew Way Beyond new rock
stars like the WWE was tweeting does he
know right like these things go Way
Beyond just the fans of our Channel and
so we thought it'd be really fun just to
kind of commemorate that by making some
special limited edition mugs with the
memes on it uh John of course has our
previous cool cool mug the mandatory fun
mug
um uh uh also limited edition fun thing
to drink out of so hey you know if
you're
that guy gets dirty
dirty wait that drinks coffee I don't
know sometimes I put my oatmeal in the
coffee mug it's like nicely you don't
just use your coffee mug for coffee no I
got coffee here I got oatmeal like I'm
trying to come up with excuses for
people to buy more than one of your soup
mug that's your macaroni and cheese
that's your coffee mug bring this if you
brought into this I am a single man
Jessica what do you expect them to own
bowls come on um if also you bring this
into your office
there's gonna be some people at the
office that's right it's gonna start
some conversations what is up with that
mug and then you're going to explain the
whole Mythos of new Rockstar uh it'll be
a blast um and we real quick want to
shout out some folks that helped us
bring this episode all we all this whole
week of episodes of the break room to
you uh hey it's 2023 and we're fortunate
enough not to be dealing with variants
of megalomaniac villain that exists
across space and time unfortunately we
do have our own Terror out here and that
terror is is iPhone bills right that
that is
um
Thanos might be behind uh attention I
use
um side note I used rocket money and
Rocket money told me what bills are
insanely too high and it's my phone it's
my phone bill my phone bill is number
one thank you other sponsor rocket money
yes and we should get on board with mint
mobile is the sponsor of today's episode
mint mobile was the first company to
sell premium wireless service online
only you order from home and save a
bunch of money with phone plan starting
at just fifteen dollars a month 15 a
month is so cheap lucky High key this is
the best business model yeah for like
who the hell is walking into a phone
store in 2023 and maybe there's some
people out there but like it's not fun
online anyways it's never a great
experience and we have multiple staff
members that have switched to Mint
mobile including uh a few of our editors
and producers they all love it they save
a bunch of money they got to keep their
phone they got to keep their phone
number all their contacts your photos
your apps whatever that's on your phone
you're not switching phones you're just
switching Service uh and they save a ton
of money they offer premium Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month by going online
only they don't have stores they cut out
that middleman they get to pass those
savings on to you uh all their plans
start with unlimited talk and text high
speed data delivered on the Nations
5G you can get unlimited text for 15
bucks hey man try it out John get on
board dude 15 bucks a month come on
switch to Mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting in just 15
bucks a month to get your new Wireless
plan uh and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com break
room that's mintmobile.com break room
how much does it cost cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month John at
mintmobile.com that not only helps you
out saves you some money it really helps
out our show we appreciate men mobile
for sponsoring us and then hey guys it's
February it's it's a lot of stuff it's
Black History Month it's um probably a
12th of the population's birthday but
it's also Factor February up in here
okay that's right uh there's nothing
worse uh than uh wrapping up a long day
at work only to face a long night of
cooking dinner our friends at Factor are
here to help you out save time and money
and energy uh with factors ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door we
are all big fans of factory they are
legitimately very tasty little meals
they come fully prepared you don't gotta
dice you don't gotta saute you don't got
to do anything you kind of pull them out
of the box you throw them in the
microwave and you're eating tasty food
uh and you don't gotta go to the grocery
store you don't got to worry about oh
I'm out of olive oil or oh no my last
eggs my eggs eggs are like 200 bucks now
uh they have meals that are keto calorie
smart vegan veggie high protein they're
all prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians each meal has all the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long you have all the
ingredients you want and nothing you
don't and I will say Factor meals are
healthy that doesn't have to be your
only reason to get them I think we all
kind of want to eat healthy whether you
have a specific kind of Health Journey
that you're on or not you know what I
mean it's just you can rest easy that
this is not like a gross kind of sodium
filled bad ready to eat meal it's one
that's good for you whether you're busy
or you're trying to eat good whatever it
doesn't matter what's that one with the
Penguin on the front the TV dinner John
Junior
if you see a John Junior TV dinner run
away my friends do not need it does that
mean he made it or does that mean he's
in it we don't know
get back here and enjoy clean eating
without the hassle uh choose your meals
and enjoy fresh flavor packed meals uh
head to Fat
factormeals.com break room 50 5.0 and
use code break room 50 to get 50 off
your first box uh that's code break room
50 5.0 at factormeals.com break room 50
to get 50 off your first box again that
helps us out and it really helps you out
we appreciate you I was trying to pull
up uh an email I got this morning my
first Factor box got delivered to my
house today and I think a couple of us
are getting uh those deliveries and so
uh tomorrow maybe we can even report
back on how tasty those bad boys were I
forgot my lunch uh at home today really
I'm starving currently I ate some
Funyuns and that's about it oh John with
Factor stuff like that I'll usually just
bring five of them in on a Monday so
that I never forget my lunch it's great
for people that you like me and you
don't eat at all because you just forget
to eat you
when I get angry guys I mean I'm
normally just a Charming blast but when
I'm hangry I'm making a test I'm no fun
uh that came into the office on a
weekend to eat a meal I love something
in the fridge
that is the definition
uh very excited to Trail Factor the rest
this week um hey back to some headlines
nine minutes of gameplay footage from
Jedi Survivor has been released uh this
is the much anticipated sequel to uh
Jedi Order Fallen order thank you
um and that got delayed about a month I
think it's coming out in April now it
was originally going to be coming out in
March uh so we're really excited to
watch this footage and then again when
the game comes out we'll probably have
some content about it on yeah let me
plays the game I think Brandon also
plays Fallen I didn't play that game I
haven't played it yet I own it uh I
haven't played it love that everyone
says everyone says calcasus is like
their favorite Jedi ever people are
dying for him to get into live action
somehow yeah
um and then as is John might have
mentioned this right uh big weekend
stuff happening this weekend right uh
the last of us will be coming out on
Friday our content around it will also
be coming out on Friday uh that also
means uh oh and that is because the
Super Bowl is on Sunday now we're
getting these trailers coming out of the
Super Bowl we know at least a handful of
the confirmed ones maybe 12 hot trailers
and and you mentioned the Marvel ones
there's also the flash is also
um fast 10 Transformers Transformers uh
dial of Destiny Indiana Jones maybe a
couple of others Little Mermaid yes
um so there's a lot to talk about so we
are going to try to go live after the
Super Bowl here at the break room Sunday
evening to react to all of these fun
trailers so tune in watch the big game
go over to your friend's house eat a lot
of delicious dips whatever and then
click over and watch us react to
something hey man you're spending 45
minutes in the bathroom after eating
we might even react to the 12 Breaking
Bad trailer
for almost 19 years they need to stop
stop them they're selling their tequila
or whatever yeah okay
um uh he said this is the last time he's
ever gonna portray Walter White in this
commercial
I know if they if they throw the bag at
you you got to put on the ball caps and
then lastly this is a really fun weird
strange headline I wouldn't call this
fun at all okay not fun it's it's just
weird and strange AMC the biggest
theater chain in North America has
announced that they will be changing
their seat pricing creating three
different pricing options based on where
the seat is in the theater uh you got
standard sight line seats that are the
most common in auditoriums and are
available
for the traditional cost of a ticket you
got value sight line seats in the front
row of the auditorium as well as
selected Ada seats in each Auditorium
it's like uh disabilities yeah they're
making them pay more they're making them
cheaper
and they're lower price than standard
sideline and then preferred sight line
seats in the middle of the auditorium
that are priced at a premium to standard
sight line seats okay uh now AMC Stubs
A-list members will be able to reserve
seats in the preferred sight line
section and no additional cost that
benefits you guys just okay that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
get everyone to get AMC sublist because
also the tickets already are 16.99 a
ticket I went and saw a movie at 7 pm a
normal time with Tommy a paper's ticket
16.99 he paid me for a second no no we I
just paid for it because I had no no
stop I'm penguin Junior no no I just
covered it because I had the app but it
was like our tickets for AMC list is 25
a month three movies a week week
yeah no the value of amca list is uh uh
we don't need to talk about it right it
is it is a great value it is if you have
an AMC nearby and you go to the movies
more than like two times a month it's
totally worth it but charging more money
for seats in the middle of a theater is
so gross the only thing I will say I I
don't hate this idea only because
a let's say you're a little strapped for
cash
even if it's a not sold out movie you
could save money by sitting in the front
row also if you're the kind of person
that doesn't care where you sit you can
save money by sitting in the very
beginning or the very front the very
back but if you're a person that values
the experience I will say I sometimes
pay more to go to a theater where they
don't play as many commercials where you
know it is a little bit better sound or
a little bit we all pay more for IMAX
when we go to IMAX so why was the value
ad there why would you pay more if you
knew you could get one of the best seats
when Regal's going down you know you
know we don't have a choice it just
feels consumer unfriendly right I I see
where your AMC marketing is do you feel
the same way about airline tickets
do you feel like you shouldn't pay more
for a an exit row or for a little bit
more lunch I do feel that way okay yeah
I only feel that way I mean look at it
like right you got Beyonce's tickets or
for her tour are out now and the tickets
for those like Beyonce Inner Circle are
like a thousand bucks over like that's
wild to me and I mean there's people
that will pay that the difference
between a floor seat at a Beyonce
concert and a nosebleeds at a Beyonce
concert is way bigger than the
difference between
this is a healthy conversation though
about it it's I'm for it I are not for
the rise of the prize but I'm for the
conversation of marketing yes and hey as
we're just in general fans are going to
the theater all movie theaters still
struggling right they've had a rough
couple years if I will I would also make
the argument even if this isn't the best
thing for fans if this somehow helps
theater stay open you know the only time
me and JB are we're okay we're gonna
open our own theater on Hollywood
Boulevard anyways
um the only way I will be happy with
this is if I'm buying a Marvel ticket at
you know midnight or 6 a.m or whatever
on the day the tickets come out and it's
the opposite of what it is now which is
like all the good seats are taken yes
and all the shitty seats are still there
if I can buy if it helps me get a better
ticket I'm all for it but I don't expect
that to be the case right I just expect
to be paying more money for the thing
that I already have well okay yeah and
and I think like we might revisit this
because I think this is really
interesting conversation as Jessica
pointed out maybe we want to get Tommy
and Brandon and some other folks that
come on the show get their opinions now
okay forget those guys uh no Brandon's
in the other room don't don't don't
threaten me with a good time
um hey let's get into this Guardians of
the Galaxy let's talk about it let's
talk about it so uh Marvel just put out
a new synopsis for this film we're
expecting a trailer on Sunday very
excited
um and the synopsis makes me very sad uh
here here it is in full in Marvel Studio
this Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 our
beloved band of Misfits are setting are
settling into life on nowhere but it
isn't long before their lives are
upended by The Echoes of rockets
turbulent past we sort of know that like
it seems like Adam Warlock is going to
kind of come and attack uh nowhere
probably sent by the high evolutionary
Peter Quill still reeling from the loss
of Gamora must rally his team around him
on a dangerous mission to and this is
the kind of the big quote to save
Rocket's life a mission that if not
completed successfully could quite
possibly lead to the end of the
Guardians as we know them so here's the
thing that kind of leads us down a
couple of paths to save Rocket's life
like a lot of people watch that trailer
and we're sort of like oh Rocket's gonna
die but it didn't seem like that was
going to be the plot of the movie right
it seemed like that might have been a
consequence of the plot of the movie we
speculated multiple characters
yeah for sure
um but this this line of like to save
Rocket's life gives us more of an
insight into what they're going to be
doing during the course of this movie we
know the high evolutionaries in this
film the person who like theoretically
created rocket
um
I think there's two paths and I want to
talk about both of them one path is high
evolutionaries running around the Galaxy
either like kidnapping people that he
considers to be his Creations or
whatever and like if if rocket perhaps
escaped he's like bring him back you you
belong here on counter Earth or wherever
they are or
this other problem of like
you know we saw in the first Guardians
of the oxy movie Rockets back and it was
like kind of gnarly it had all these
things right
um we also see a shot in the trailer
where like there's more of his implants
kind of poking through it looks like
he's like deteriorating a little bit you
could argue maybe that's just because
he's gotten roughed up a little bit but
we haven't seen that happen in previous
movies so I think the second possibility
is
something about these implants is
killing rocket right he has a short
shelf life he was experimented on the
experiments are failing they only had a
certain you know amount of uh technology
breaks down over time right and like
what if this story is going to be Rocket
needing to find the high evolutionary in
order to like fix himself and there's
going to be this weird kind of like
you know battle between rocket wanting
to find the high evolutionary to fix
himself and the high evolutionary coming
after the Guardians and coming after
rocket to kind of like clean up his
mistakes or whatever it is and I I kind
of want to go back so your first thing
so like you're saying kind of the two
potentials there they got to save
Rocket's life either because save him
from the high evolutionary killing him
yeah or save him by getting to the high
evolutionary to get a cure or some kind
of Aid or a fun we haven't seen we
haven't
really seen a Marvel movie where the
heroes need to go find the villain in
order to save the world right we got
that a little bit in end game where they
need to go find Thanos and they chop his
head off and they think that you know
they didn't do anything the red herring
um
but I like this idea of like
the main character one of the main
characters in the movie needed to
actively seek out a villain and the like
weird situation that that puts everyone
else in yeah I think that would also
play in line like we know Adam Warlock
and the high evolutionary are going to
be some kind of antagonists in this
movie we don't know that they're aligned
they could be separate right Adam Rock
could just be coming from Aisha and all
the gold people right and like it's a
totally separate issue dealing with the
high evolutionary the high evolutionary
right it's going to have a longer life
in the MCU than I'm sorry we suspect
that Adam Warlock is going to have a
longer life in the MCU than the high
evolutionary potentially being on the
side of the Guardians or on the side of
the Avengers in the future maybe
um so like you know does does Adam
Warlock become an ally by the end of
this film you know rocket is if rocket
is a creation of the high evolutionary
which we highly suspect if Adam Warlock
is the creation of the high evolutionary
which we're starting to suspect like
does that put them on the same side
against this common enemy and that's how
you can kind of get them towards
interesting yeah I don't know huh uh I I
like and then I want to revisit your
second thing they have to chase down the
high vote they have to chase them down
for a cure or something like that shades
of Mighty for Mighty Thor Jane Foster
suffering from cancer a little bit like
a little bit of race against the clock
kind of a thing that is kind of heavy
and relatable but James kind of said
this is kind of a tear-jerker movie
right and then I think you know that
puts rocket in this really interesting
position as a character of like
can I save myself
and not potentially harm my friends
right he if he needs to get to the high
evolutionary in order to save himself
what's that mean for the rest of the
Guardians of the Galaxy they have to
come against this huge Foe and is he
gonna have to make this choice of like
you know maybe I don't
live through this movie uh in order to
keep my friends safe uh you can
certainly see a scenario he's trying to
sacrifice himself to save them they're
trying to sacrifice themselves
yeah I don't know just of those two
options right the kidnapping versus this
maybe like they have to go get something
from the high evolutionary do you fall
on one side or the other
um I'm listening because
I'm not trying to spoil anything oh
oh we might get some of these characters
showing up
interesting interesting interesting well
don't spoil anything yeah I'm not going
to spoil anything yeah in a hypothetical
situation in which you did not know what
happens in quantumania
I think that
I I think John answered a lot of it uh
of just being like
them searching for
the high evolutionary to fix rocket
and I agree with that
and offline I will tell you guys yeah
well because you know it feels too it
feels too easy it feels too convenient
to be like hey we kidnapped Rocket
Raccoon and now it's like the Guardians
have to go save rocket yeah wow they
have to go find Gamora and like get her
involved again it's like that seems a
little kind of like convenient but also
repetitive and also where where has he
been why kidnap him now not in the last
two movies right uh I think that's a
really good point I also said now I
don't know this could play in any of
these theories but like a franchise that
started these characters met in prison I
do like the idea ending back in prison
but that could be either way that could
be like you know you could see a
scenario rocket kind of breaks off on
his own he's like I don't want to drag
you guys into this he seeks out the high
evolutionary who then with bad intent
kidnaps you know is not like he's gonna
he's not a good guy he's not just gonna
cure rocket and send him on his way and
they have to go kind of save him from
that and then they gets complicated
because that may not lead to a cure
right and I think rocket has shown that
kind of like [__] you guys I'm gonna go
off on my own side of him in the past I
can't think of a specific example but
like that feels very intrinsic to
Rockets he's Sullen right yeah he's like
I don't need you uh I'm gonna go solve
my problem by myself stay out of my
business a little bit I'll take my
little tree with me and uh you guys will
deal with your own self yeah I I like
both of these and honestly you can see
the like dramatic potential both these
could be really powerful storytelling
things right like you know this whole
like the the one of the overarching
themes of the Guardians movies is this
family is is how you find yourself you
know the groups that you find yourself
in it's not necessarily who you were
born into in fact often the people
you're born to are not very nice to you
or whatever right it's your passing your
eyes with cybernetic yeah you know we're
a weird planet gods that only want to
harvest you or whatever right and it's
your found family that's like you know
your deepest connection and so like this
idea of like ah maybe a you know one of
those people is sick and like doesn't
want to drag the family down but the
family's like no no like we want to be
there for you in your hard times or
whatever and I can you see an ending of
this movie where like
somehow rocket removes the cybernetic
implants in him that allow him to talk
and all that kind of stuff and we have a
character like Cosmo who can talk with a
different piece of technology we don't
know where that Tech has come from like
isn't that kind of a a resolution that
we could see right like I'm giving this
up but I'm also kind of getting
something back and we also know he gets
connected with Lila the the cute little
otter kind of girlfriend character
flashback maybe not true but maybe they
like both kind of get their implants
removed and then just go get deliveries
as someone from the Pacific Northwest I
can tell you right now otters and
raccoons do not get a lot of them
as soon as little raccoons washing their
hands in the water though
um but I also yeah I just imagine that
once you take out their implants they
just go back to yeah I mean they
probably lose their memories
Rockets and the little trailer they were
like they have their little implants but
I assume would you take those out they
just go back maybe I do like you know it
is it is a fun choice to be that you
know the plot seems to be swirling
around rocket in this third movie right
that he's kind of like the heart of the
group that they are like and it kind of
makes sense right like even though he's
like this very unusual creature who's
not like human or humanoid even like
also he's the only one that survived
other than uh Nakamura um the sister
nebula
yeah that's right it's just those two so
it's like we've been following that
those two technically the one or well
him the longest because she wasn't there
in the first movie so it's like oh well
she kind of was but you know what I mean
you know what I mean she was a part of
he was a part of the team the longest
that's a good point uh so he it's like
full circle for him I think we we know
everyone else is like full origin with
Drax and everything else so it's like
let's see it physically let's see this
one oh
um before we go yes before we move on
you've mentioned Drax
I want from both of you who's more
likely to to die at the end of this
movie Dave Batista said this is a slash
movie that doesn't necessarily mean he
dies he could also be like [__] with
everyone right
um and they could get a different Muscle
Man and put him in the green painted
uh rocket from the trailers looks like
he's not gonna make it plus it's easier
to kill I feel like people keep thinking
that scene of Chris Pratt crying the
starler crying is over him but I think
it's a flashback to his mom and they're
making
oh no they're making him the high
evolutionaries making him see it like
live in the same room as his mom dying
in the hospital uh I'm not that that's
gonna mess me up
um I don't know if it's over rocket but
I I I'm so sorry I stand the difference
he's gonna die because those interviews
he genuinely does want to get out I
think Batista 100 dead no offense I
think they find a way to make rocket
live I think only because like again
he's kind of the heart of that it also
if there's a new iteration of the
Guardians after this movie right like
the original cast is kind of like you
know piecing out so you think like
rocket could be the new leader he's the
new kind of star-lord-ish figure and
maybe also mantis you know where you
kind of build something new around
rocket man just Adam Warlock whoever
I'll say this too right like James Gunn
for all of the
um you know he's he's not afraid to kill
off characters but he does like a happy
ending right like you know sure maybe
Guardians 2 is a little melancholic
where you know uh yanu dies it's like a
funeral and that's that's pretty sad but
like the Guardians accomplish their
goals and they're going to be better
people this Suicide Squad I think like
rat catcher 2 had like a pretty nice
ending not really the end of that movie
um
so like I don't think that James Gunn is
going to make necessarily like a really
Downer end and end to this film which
makes me think maybe rocket could live
and and starts a new a new Garden right
right yeah yeah because if this is the
rocket movie you're protagonist and and
I think the movie I think that's a great
Point John and I think just like Tony
Stark dying uh and Captain America
retiring doesn't end The Avengers yeah I
think a couple of these characters dying
retiring going off to do their own thing
doesn't end the guardian so and we end
on like yay new Guardian somebody else
is in the ship right like in kind of a
more positive way and so Sylvester
Stallone is signed on to a six-year
dealer that 90 year old Sylvester
Stallone will still be piloting
that's whatever
I say yeah this is Drax 100 dead rocket
I'll put it at a 30 percent
okay uh we want to shout out a couple
thank you to everybody that's sending
super chats Boogie's World nice to hear
from you Daniel fontanez saying liked it
I'm gonna assume that was the AMC
pricing uh thing
like the stream oh okay like oh you like
the video yeah like subscribe that's
great our Canadian friend Christian
unpronounceable setting in one what if
born again is the full 20 episodes in a
row but it interacts with other MCU
properties along its run I would like
that it takes place in New York still
right he's not it's like like there's a
three episode Arc that's like Ghost
Rider shows up or something like that I
would love that that'd be interesting
it is 18 episodes which is a great
multiple of three you know we had the
Andor structure of Three episodes three
episodes three episodes
um yeah that would be very I think it's
a really fun idea I did hear this
disgusting rumor which is again again a
rumor probably not true we in the office
kind of were like
that is like a red flag rumor that
doesn't make sense to us that like coven
of chaos might get delayed until after
born again which makes me think that
like born again could have big MCU
implications like that like why would
you but I don't see how those two shows
are connected
it it doesn't make so that's why I'm
saying like it doesn't make sense yeah
but tell that rumor that it's a liar
that's right oh so I don't like any
rumor that stuff getting delayed we need
stuff earlier Jason morante is saying
sneaking in the chat will it work hey
don't get fired Jason morante whatever
you do don't get fired I get fired have
more time to watch no that's bad phrase
his his life you're right my friend GSU
Eagle FYI what kind of forever physical
Blu-ray came out today I was getting my
week's fixed up also we had our content
meeting last week and I was like Yeah
Tuesday the 7th and then when you
brought it up I was like yesterday
because we don't have the break room on
Monday it shifts everything for me it
genuinely does I don't know how to work
thank you GSU and then Quentin thank you
for your Super Chat thank you to
everybody that was in the chat today we
appreciate you
um I should go buy one
um the Blu-ray at Best Buy because I do
like the idea that there's a wakanda
version and a toloken version that's so
cool
also physical media guys it ain't dead
that's right
these streamers will take your content
away if you don't own it uh thank you
everybody uh for watching the show today
for joining us again we've got a really
big week this week uh yesterday we had a
Last of Us uh after show Friday we'll
have another Last of Us after show
Sunday we'll have a big Super Bowl uh
multi-trailer reaction video we're gonna
go nuts on that uh and then we've got
some fun stuff in between yeah and then
the following week is deep dive
quantumania crazy weekend I mean the
following week is too much can't even
talk about it yet it's too much uh thank
you all for watching head over to nerd
riot.shop and grab yourself one of these
goofy mugs and most importantly keep it
Gucci Gucci bye
[Music]